good day today is Friday and I have my
little sidekick right now taika who's
supposed to be in school but what
happened
[Applause]
[Music]
to school today but we'll just take a
day off yeah so not because we wanted to
take day off it's I think they have like
a teacher's training so we decided to
come on a hike God dang look at those
big old like
duh get away you see that big old bug
it's huge huh I think he wants to play
[Applause]
the bug wants to play a game with Mia
yeah I hope Mia bites it so it leaves us
alone but uh yeah decided to come out
take taika out it's like eight in the
morning still
um so it's not too hot it's perfect
spring weather right now in Vegas
we a cactus
yeah don't Mia ah oh my gosh she just
bumped into it
she just bumped into it oh God again oh
no come here come here sit sit sit miss
it
Mia look at her wait sit
look
wait it's not funny it's ah look
look at it look at the needle
probably but she doesn't she's not a big
baby she doesn't even care no yeah so
decided to come out to Red Rock get a
little hike in especially for Mia
because she just kind of stays cooped in
all day just because I work from home
Tech is at school
um and I'm just working the whole time
what
everywhere in the backyard
yep that's her job just to poop
um so I liked it here so that she can
just
roam free because we can't really even
do that at parks when we take tiger to a
park she has to be on a leash and
so I don't know I like it here because
everyone could be free you can't get in
trouble other than getting stung by a
cactuses
but you're not supposed to in Nevada
it's against the law you're supposed to
keep your dogs on the leash in public
places
it's not a leash Alicia's a leash
this was that e-collar it's the trainer
yeah okay so we are at this one I think
is called Lost Creek Canyon never been
here there's so many cool hikes in the
uh
in the uh Red Rock
hiking trails like whatever you call
this place National Park
um so this is one I haven't been on so
super stuck to see what it is
I'm hoping there's water right we saw
that there was water in pictures I used
the app all Trails oh I see I use all
trails app and then it showed me that
there was water so
it looks promising from the picture so
we'll see so we think we hear water
right taika
oh yeah
there it is
here
it's getting louder what does that mean
what if what does it mean if it's
getting louder
are we getting closer or further away
well this is pretty what
cool
this is beautiful
oh
come here
let's see
come on Mia
yay she's so excited
this Trail just keeps getting cooler and
cooler look at that
looks like a forest
and I'm just falling
taika but really the all Trails map
okay Mia how you gonna do this let's go
come on Mia
really
come
on okay
on oh that was easy
it ain't no thing for the Mia follow you
what
[Applause]
hold on
someone
okay what did we find
what
it's a little underwhelming but we
didn't Mia come
so cool yeah go ahead
so cool
Mama huh okay
[Music]
via the water pup
are you gonna get underneath the
waterfall
you think so
so cool
you got wet
[Music]
go where the water is
look how beautiful this tree
no stand right there in the middle
oh yeah
yeah go in the middle
do it fast
in the middle in the middle
in the middle over there
yeah yeah yeah
in the middle more that way more that
way
going really fast go
right there right there right there yeah
yeah go go go more forearm go forward go
forward
okay
[Music]
oh are you okay
it's okay
get it there's only one way to get it
careful because that Rock's gonna be
slippery okay
The Rock's gonna be slippery
Mia Mia get his hat
get his hat Mia
go down yeah that way that way that way
no keep coming down no no no no no down
the middle
why
okay
[Music]
whoa careful
you having fun
run really fast go run you got it Go
Sonic go
go Sonic go
you did it oh my God Mia you having fun
how did you like it
before we even came here so I was like I
don't want to do 100 so boring and then
I was like dude there's gonna be water
he's like I'm in
so do you approve do you want to come
back
all right what are we gonna do now
play baseball we're gonna play some
baseball
nope
oh it's okay I'll show them later
I'll show you later yep
they peed in the ocean put it in the
water and then drink it
[Applause]
really disgusting right now disgusting
Mia Mia
Mia you're gross
she's laughing she goes ha ha ha
ha so we were about to go play baseball
at the park but what happened monkey
what happened what did we do what did we
just do right now
I don't know how this happened but we're
getting donuts some Randy's Donuts they
have this in California La never went
but it's here now and now I freaking
love it oh my God they're warm I feel it
oh my legs are warm okay I can't open
the box
I don't know I don't know why I don't
know what's going on but I can't open it
but we'll open it at the park and I got
myself a coffee you ready yeah please
wait oh my God
hi Mia hello the moment of truth
first
a little plate
we're at the park now we're at this park
called Fox Hills it is so rad
look at all that the doctor said
it's so much space
and for the dogs to play and the kids to
play there's just so much room for
activities
okay so the camera's about to die I
didn't charge it I'm freaking dumb
um but I'm gonna play the park with
taika and then I will charge it and I'll
see you in a bit tiger where you at
okay ready to go
you have yeah I feel there oh no
okay
no good
well it has a lot so Tyga just woke up
from his nap whoa and what are you doing
now
spaghetti we're gonna make some
spaghetti for dinner
oh slow and steady slow and steady
okay I think that's enough it has a
whole bunch yep that's a whole bunch
there's no more no dude we don't need
any more now we can put it on the stove
you can leave it there for now
I'll do it I'll put on the stuff you
move your little doggy step
why are you wearing my shoes
because my shoes are not fit on me
anymore okay I'm too young I'll turn off
you're too young huh okay so we're gonna
let the
we're gonna let the what are you doing
not yet not yet we have to let the water
boil
oh okay
did you wash your hands
oh it's that kind of a restaurant huh
it's a Chinese restaurant huh
Chinese
Italian huh
yeah
I like your hair dude
so what's going on with the hair tell me
what's going on with the hair what are
we doing with this hair are we cutting
it anytime soon no mama why why are you
snatching it for me I'm not snatching it
from you why you keep pulling it down oh
because you need to wash your hands
we're gonna eat this this is food don't
tell me about your hair are we gonna cut
it anytime soon no it's zero percent no
I'm gonna look like a girl
you don't just because you have long
hair doesn't mean you look like a girl
just means you have your boy with long
hair
that's all it means look at me I don't
have long hair and I'm a girl I have
short hair no you have long hair it's
almost as long as yours mine is like up
to here too no but I don't have this
part mine is just all one life
is tied up and then if you take it out
it gets how long how long this long yeah
it's only up to here yeah your hair is
up to there too right now right there no
mine is right here oh hey
I like your pajamas
what is it okay and what happened here
oh a woman's children why that's
probably why you were so hot no no I
didn't put them on I took them out and
they went back on but she put them back
on me my brother who she is your brother
and bushy is also your oh you turn off
the
bushy is also your
um blanket oh and your blanket and your
brother yeah and if you put on
while I was sleeping
oh he's a crazy kid
yes so what are you gonna do you're
gonna keep him these I love it he's he
knows not to do that he's already 11
years old he makes so many faces you're
so how old are you dude you act like
you're 11. are you 11 years old she is
oh he's 11. and he knows not to put on
my shorts especially when you're
sleeping yeah
he's teaching that I was this teacher
what did you teach him not to put on
when people are sleeping not to put on
their regular color where they were just
wear it that's so rude why did he do
that
no I just she not wants to do that oh
yeah yeah what are we gonna do to him
spank him
this is a big hair he just laughs he
thinks it's funny yeah what oh what if
we put him in the washer
he'll care
what if we put him in the fire what if
we burn him oh you don't care but then
you know what's gonna happen What you're
not gonna have a brother anymore he's
gonna turn into Ash
so you want to burn them
oh my mom I have a whole bunch of
Brothers show me the other ones while we
wait for the water ball here show me
your other brothers yeah let's go you
can put my shoes away too because I
don't want you
walking around with dirty shoes
[Music]
I like how you
how you put right next to them
Mia's been so tired from today's hike
and park that's not my brother that's my
sister oh okay
she didn't lose a nail
yeah
every time okay
punch me a lot like an old lady
okay a dog called him everyone
man we gotta clean this room dude
ah what's his name Huggy wuggy yucky
yucky look at his teeth
isn't he a bad guy
oh okay he never puts on my shorts okay
he doesn't do it who else is your
brother
get out of here
Spider-Man's her brother okay
beat him up you know who's gonna have to
pick that up right yeah okay
just reminding you
I think a monkey should write it hiding
in the background why because he's
beating up another monkey
and he knows not to beat up another
monkey
and he still beats up on the once he
even beat up the monkey no it's a Super
Monkey he's a Super Monkey
oh there he is
how long have you had monkey chiro for
whoa that's another monkey
okay are those all your brothers
don't punch him okay
okay
she's coming now
okay any more Brothers yep there's like
a lot oh shoot okay
the
oh that's another brother for sure
okay that's enough we'll do some more oh
okay
so much are they hiding
yeah oh okay
one is in the room
which one what what one brother's in you
hiding in your one brother is hiding in
your in your room
what what the oh found one again
oh yeah that's another brother for sure
oh that's another one another one oh
true oh my God you do have a lot of
brothers
and this one
this one oh yeah
oh my God
those bad brothers got it okay monks got
it thank you so much for sharing one
more height it's in your room okay it's
Gucci what a bad boy
I want to vacuum up I want to vacuum up
put your vacuum
okay
you're so cute
I don't know oh excuse me
so every time Papa oh my God you're in
his pants every time papa is out of
state he facetimes us from wherever he's
at right now he's in Texas okay get it
get him out of your pants
foreign
[Music]
get him out he says it smells give him
give me the phone
no that's it that's it that's it here
did you see his hair
are you did it again okay
there he is hey no I can't hear you
anymore
so I lost my helper
yeah because I was you were supposed to
help me make the spaghetti the
spaghetti's made and nobody helped me
you
yeah
so take that is eating sahaba Bubba
what is this called Bubble tape
ice as a kid you know that
open your mouth
oh my God no
no okay what are we doing right now dude
we're shooting each other we're shooting
each other
oh I like you but yeah we're shooting
oh we're pretending we're going around
the house
okay I think he's gonna try to shoot me
how do I this
and we're trying to shoot each other
whoa
ah
[Applause]
you caught me you win
no okay
your mouth that was good what's
happening
excuse me
[Applause]
thank you dude
how much gum do you have oh it's huge
all right monkey
who won that challenge
I don't know I think we were tied I
think you got me you I like beat you
five times in a row and then you beat me
like five times in a row I think I beat
you four
okay we'll do a rematch tomorrow yeah
I think that was a lot of fun thank you
for taking that game and letting me play
we need a piece of paper oh we'll keep
score yeah
[Music]
yeah okay dude that gum is crazy dude
okay what are you gonna do now
people
nobody gonna do now
take a shower and then
no you're not don't do that oh
my God okay
so
on that note that game was a lot of fun
actually we were getting very strategic
and trying to like really like be
aggressive and attacking each other Tyga
would run up on me I would run up on him
it was a lot of fun we are gonna play
tomorrow so we're gonna do a rematch but
until then
so you guys tomorrow because I just got
a stinky butt he's got a shower all
right stinky butt what oh smell it guys
smell the sticky butt smell his stinky
butt